back to Manny Pacquiao if we can get
this message to him any perineum what
are you doing man this is the biggest
fight of his life he fought big big
players he win some he lost some but to
really to be a true champion of life a
true boxer you have to box with the
shaitaan' Manny you know what you got to
do you have to bug the Shaitan kick him
out and and become a true champion of
the people and the most famous monogram
is lapu lapu lapu lapu is a Muslim hero
with the first Muslim hero who fought
magellan army I think many if you truly
love your people you want the best for
them right and and and the best for them
is Islam so as as also you I know before
the Spanish came and basically why part
a big majority of this must actually
when you say proudly your Filipino
you're indirectly saying well I'm a I'm
basically a slave of the the one who
colonized me which is which was the King
Phillip at the time assalamu alaikum
greetings apiece welcome back to the D
show and I'm here with our brother
Julian and we were talking about
something some very interesting
information about some of the time you
spent in the Philippines and I thought
those gems of wisdom that you share with
us of some of the history of the
Filipino people that they don't even
know about many of them but when you
talk to him about these gems about their
history being deeply embedded in Islam
this is a great piece of information
just that in and of itself and other
things you're going to share with us
that many people don't know with us so
please enlighten us with some of these
interesting facts about the Filipino
people so actually I lived for years in
the Philippines I did some reports there
and became a Muslim in the Philippines
so of course I'm very interested about
history and I found out actually was
a Muslim country such as Indonesia
Malaysia there was a lot of saltiness
and before the Spanish came and
basically why parts a big majority of
this Muslim they even had a hero but
actually if you go in the central part
of the Philippines of Manila in the
capital you will see a bunch of statues
of Muslim heroes and the most famous
monogram is lapu lapu lapu lapu is a
Muslim hero with the first Muslim hero
who fought Magellan army and you know to
resist against the oppressor and the
aggressors and the tragedy is that they
got rid of all the parents and they kept
the children and give them Spanish
numbers while every Filipino has a
Spanish name the name of Sanchez
you know Delgado you know so that's what
Arroyo so I always happen in the history
and and yes the the the Philippines
don't know that actually the name
Philippines comes from the King Philip
II you know and actually when you say
proudly your Filipino you're indirectly
saying well I'm I'm basically a slave of
the the one who colonized me which is
which was the King Phillip at the time
you know so it's a good piece of
information and it's always good to know
your history and of course the history
got eradicated you know for political
purpose but if you you should be proud
of your Muslim heritage and come back to
it that's why when a Filipino become
Muslim we we say in Tagalog Ballack
Islam because you are returning to the
original faith of your forefathers of
your ancestors which was Islam now
you're in your experience and talking to
how much time did you spend you're
actually a French citizen right yes and
how much time did you spend in the
Philippines I spent four years four
years working there I traveled all over
the Philippines from from Manila to Cebu
to
Mindanao and when you bring these very
important points of history up in these
facts what has been the reaction of many
many Filipinos it was very positive
actually they were very grateful for
this piece of informations and most of
them when I talk to them you know they
appreciate this and some of them become
Muslims
no because Filipinos are very sincere
people they sincerely worship God the
only thing is because they just followed
what the forefathers did and they just
don't know the right path but once you
tell them they really usually have no
problem to accept the truth you know but
it's all about informing you know it's
it's population of one and million
people so it takes time and it's just
happening step by step and it's just
next time for them to get it but there
are really good people and they usually
accept the truth very easily they are
not arrogant
like other nations what about Manny
Pacquiao Manny Pacquiao is one of the
most famous Filipinos right yeah I
actually had a picture with him when he
was a congressman and I'm gonna picture
like this with him like I was about to
boxing as a joke but after this day I
never really had a time to talk to him I
was not Muslim at the time when I met
him so of course Manny Pacquiao is from
Mindanao he's a very dedicated Christian
and we hope and pray if it's not the
case already maybe he did it already but
yeah he has a huge potential to become
as him such as a president 230
you know as a great relationship with
the Muslims and he so so the potential
is very no Robin Padilla one of the
biggest star actors in the Philippines
became azim you have Freddie Aguilar
which was a fork singer who made a big
hit with a song became Muslim so a few
leaders among the community I became
Muslim already you know it's just a
matter of time actually but you know the
truth will be even more you know a
parent I believe did
is this true I heard that the president
of the Philippines that he made a
statement saying that he does not
believe in the Trinity there's only one
God you cannot divide God into three
that's silly
that he believes in God and that he
believes in Allah have you heard this I
have to say since I left the Philippines
I I didn't really I have not have not
heard that
yeah could he have said it possibly but
I you know as a as a journalist
background I I won't take this we need
yeah we needed today to investigate you
know I think the brother was telling me
that oh you weren't there when he was
talking I was not okay so maybe we could
verify this this is the brother I don't
know you could have said it privately or
publicly this I don't know but
definitely is is a sympathizer of the
machines and despite all the things that
have been said about him on the Western
news I believe is much better than his
predecessors because I was actually
working during the time of his
predecessors and of course when
president doesn't want to be a puppet of
the West you always get the backlash of
it but I as I said I don't know you know
I don't know what what is he really
doing on the ground because I don't live
anymore in the Philippines for the past
five years they're back to Manny
Pacquiao if we can get this message to
him any penny up what are you doing man
we're waiting for you I mean how okay
this is I mean this is profound baby
because before before this before the
colonization they were majority Muslims
but so they would link their history
their roots to Islam so now they got
colonized they they got converted over
to another religion from away from their
their original way of life even going
beyond that if you go back to the to the
first man Adam and then the prophets and
all they all submitted their will to the
crater that has an air of the all did
Islam they were once who submitted to
the will of God they were Muslim so what
else would you say to Manny Pacquiao do
you also speak Filipino Cantillon
Cantillon a little bit so what would you
say to someone like it who he does I
mean you know he's a strong Christian
and obviously many Christians are also
coming to Islam because they see the
contradiction there between you know
belief in God and then worshipping Jesus
and Islam is directly just worshiping
the Creator the one God they see many of
the contradictions with the Trinity and
the Bible and what not Islam clears all
that up what would you tell him what
would you communicate him well all I can
say is Manny Pacquiao he loves these
people when if a hero truly loved the
Filipino and I think Manny if you truly
love your people you want the best for
them right and and and the best for them
is Islam
so as you I know you also truly love God
so if you truly love God find find the
true religion that leads to God you know
so we are all on this journey you know
and I mean he has a potential and you
have the many as a potential to become a
great Muslim because you have so many
good character and you know I just hope
that you will be guided by Allah you
know if it's not already the case but we
need people like you to join us on
because you are the ambassador of your
country and we are we are waiting for
for you to join this great religion
where the the fastest growing religion
in the world and and people like you
truly love God and truly love the
Filipinos will be a very important part
of this revival of Islam
Felipe's insha'Allah it reminds me of
great Christians of the past like
majeski when one of the Companions of
the last and final measure sent to
mankind the Prophet Muhammad peace and
blessings be upon him he stood in front
of the joshi Jaffa may Allah have mercy
on he after he explained Islam this is
the Christian ruler of that time he said
the Christian he said now because the
pagan Arabs had come and they were
trying to take them back and they escape
the persecution this shows the Justice
of this Christian king he was a great
user you know a great Christian king who
later is known that he accepted Islam
but at that moment a Christian he said
after hearing the message he said I will
not sell you out for a mountain of gold
No so then you also have another
Christian at that time at the time of
the Prophet Muhammad peace and blessing
be upon them now remember these were
sincere people they were looking to the
pleasure of God they weren't looking for
popularity for fame for any of these
things so one thing is sincerity with
your Creator within yourself he also
said look if I can be with you if I was
younger and still be around I would be
with you when your people are gonna
persecute you for what that message of
la ilaha illa-llah
there's nothing worthy of worship except
the Creator that happens in the earth
just like Moses Jesus and all of them
were persecuted so people like Manny
Pacquiao you know now it's like that
test you know my people love me but what
would the people also say are they
worrying about you know losing that
popularity are they gonna catch some
heat what's the status over there when
someone does accept this no I would say
this is the biggest fight of his life he
fought big big players he wins some he
lost some but to really to be a true
champion of life a true boxer you have
to box with the Shaitan that's your main
enemy and otherwise you're gonna end up
losing so as a champion money you know
what you got to do you have to buck the
Shaitaan kick him out and and become a
true champion of the people the true
champion of a religion that is the only
way to lead you to paradise and then you
your legacy will forever be because you
know as a champion in 30 years time
nobody will remember we
it's just the fact I mean who remember
Muhammad Ali
talk about the our generation is gonna
lose I mean he's still there but think
about one who was before Muhammad Ali
the the best remembered it was the
before there was a great box actually
was French French I forgot his name
isn't so in 30 years time
Muhammad Ali people would forget and in
in maybe 60 years time we will remember
Manny Pacquiao in the Philippines but if
you become a same I can guarantee you
who you name will be remembered for
centuries yeah
and that's interesting you remember
Muhammad Ali but it's it Allah the
Creator elevated him because of that
because he accepted Islam and it's to
occur there's a different things they're
correcting that became Muslim but
because he became Muslim his legacy will
go on
it's amazing that like that legacy of
him you see that it just it just
continued to rise because he was a
humanitarian he did things that were
Aslam motivated him to do to helping to
change mankind this is actually Muhammad
Ali was a big part of when I was because
I'm a lot of support and he has very big
speech about him you know we have such a
short amount of time to live and out to
be really so definitely I mean thanks
for correcting me because Muhammad Ali
doesn't fall into this category he
became Muslim already but many champion
are getting forgotten you know you know
think about Michael Jordan now LeBron
James and Kobe Bryant is trying to stay
in the game but Michael you lost you
lost it
that is people are coming at you now to
take to take the leadership of this NBA
and you too Michael if you're watching
this you know I carry my bull
abdul-jabbar is the biggest core of Nu
and he's already a Muslim you want to be
a true champ Karim abdul-jabbar
his legacy is going to go on and on but
but you know Michael we are waiting for
you as well from Chicago like my brother
here we're coming at you I like you in a
beautiful example of people will forget
and when people do small things like
that just look at Habib you know he
mentions God he's trying to live
identify as a Muslim and
my tea elevates you now and you're able
to stand out because you are preaching
the truth thank you so much I mean and
you mentioned one more thing and it's in
the Koran murmee yeah bottarga al-islam
Medina and follow you cobalamin whoo-hoo
to me now Farsi Dean this is like I'm
not an Arab he's not an Arab but we got
the living language of a book that's
preserved tamper free tamper proof it
invites you to challenge it put it to
the test if it was from other than the
crater that happens on earth you would
find contradictions discrepancies in it
and what I just recited was the original
Arabic he's learning and I'm learning
every Muslim who's a Muslim is helping
to preserve this book and in this says
that the Creator that heavens and earth
Allah he said that there's no other way
of life that will be accepted accepts
submission to his will I understand that
and that's equal in one word Islam and
everything else anyone else following
anything else in the hereafter they'll
be among the losers so let's be among
the winners the chance amid the
champions submit our will to the crater
that heavens into earth avoid the
Hellfire get to Jannah paradise and
that's by worshiping only one God the
crater that was in earth makes sense
he did it I did it you can do it let's
do it I'm signing for this peace be with
you keep tuning in subscribe if you
haven't already
assalamualaikum Dominick